it's rare for the Northeast to be
rattled by an earthquake but it happened
yesterday just after 4:45 p.m. did you
guys feel that no my whole life is an
earthquake be honest the 4.1 magnitude
quake was centered near Dover Delaware
it was felt from Washington DC to
northern New York no injuries or damages
were reported in Lonnie Quinn chief
weather caster of our New York station
WCBS is here with more on the quake
Lonnie did you feel it not not chipper
or shaken up this is the sort of
earthquake that would have made
chandelier swing the closer you were to
the epicenter but let's talk about the
whole thing because look the East Coast
gets earthquakes but earthquakes of this
magnitude are extremely rare and when
they do happen they're often felt in an
area more than 10 times larger then if a
similar magnitude of earthquake was to
hit the west coast and the reason is the
rock here in the East Coast is generally
colder and it's more condensed and that
combination allows the energy to travel
farther okay so now we can talk about
why the whole event was so rare in
California you know he just heard from
Blatt
there are tons and tons of earthquakes
right because the state lies on the San
Andreas Fault that's the most famous
fault line and that's where two tectonic
plates are overlapping the North
American plate and the Pacific plate and
those two plates they move up to two
inches a year and there's this enormous
amount of energy that builds up there
and when they move even a fraction of an
inch
well the stress that gets released can
cause an earthquake meanwhile here on
the East Coast
it's got fault lines sure but it's in
the center of that North American plate
and it is possible that this earthquake
was the result of the movement of a
long-dormant fault line or the formation
of a relatively new fault line we just
don't know since there are far fewer
earthquakes here in the east